single mothers
I don't think we get the same stigma
because I think statistically if a child
is raised in a single father household
they actually do better surprisingly
enough I think when I first heard that I
was like shocked by that I think there's
reasons for it I think in general not
always like this is a general rule our
temperaments are the same throughout the
throughout the year so we don't have
obviously the time of the month or
anything so I think we can be consistent
whereby if obviously for Charles raised
in with a single parent single mom
household obviously there's different
times whereby if she's going for a
maestro Circle her mood may change and
that could affect the child as well so
like a chauvinist yeah yeah I am I do
believe in the patriarchy
really you sound like a misogynist
um do do baby fathers get the same
stigma
I think that's a bit of a silly comment
to be honest with you to say that
children are impacted by the menstrual
cycle of their mother they are we're
chemically different every single day
it's confusing for a child that's why
men are fathers statistically are better
like raising kids after the age of eight
because it's confusing but to use that
as a measure of like how well a parent
parents it's not saying I'm not I'm not
putting criticism on the mum it's just
how how it is yeah
yeah for example I've always said men
tend to go with their intellect where
women tend to go with their intuition
that's our difference it's not a
criticism it's just the way we're built
yeah yeah I can't just do that and
obviously there is a difference
it's the same reason like women have the
majority of the debt is because we're
more influenced by like emotion and like
ad campaigns are typically targeted
towards women
but are you are we are we like looking
at that as as an effective parent or is
it well no I'm saying I'm saying it's
the same like the same reason is because
we're more governed by emotions it's the
same reason like men or kids tend to do
better with single fathers over single
mothers
over the age of eight okay yeah hence
why the two parent household is the best
solution is the best solution 100
I would have to agree
you would have to agree with me
well I agree that
um you know with what this gentleman
here is saying they know it makes sense
well I agree with the statistics it does
actually make sense I haven't read the
statistics but it doesn't make sense
because as you said women are governed
by our emotions this is why two parent
household is necessary men and women
were not the same it creates a balance
yep and we need each other exactly
interdependent exactly so for me I have
two nieces and a nephew and I look after
them sometimes and I feel like when I
see the mom involved and the father
involved my brother there's more of a
disciplinary
energy that my brother holds that he'll
be able to come in and be more bit
structured and you know I guess govern a
situation in a different way not to say
it's better but in a different way and
when those two solutions and those two
different perspectives come together
it works it's you know it's the way the
most I intended it to be so yeah and
plus remember back in the old days what
would mothers always say to the children
wait to your father yes
yeah and I agree I'd have to agree yeah
so I have a question do you guys like
when at what point
should mothers put their happiness above
their kids because we know that single
parent households like kids are at a
disadvantage right so for me like I
don't think there's really a good reason
to break up a home outside of like
extreme cheating abuse like like the
extreme scenarios because I feel like as
a mother you should want to put your
kids happiness above your own yeah I
agree I think um I think that no point
sorry
um I think once you have children you
have to understand that it's no longer
about you you have to become selfless
and um yeah your children are Paramount
how realistic is that in these days in
time zone
um
um I don't know I don't know I just I
just think you feel like women I take it
I put in their happiness before their
children definitely and most definitely
I think most definitely I think a lot of
women nowadays if you want to say modern
day women they're very materialistic you
know very very materialistic it's like
what you said we're more likely to be in
debt and things like that because I
guess we'll want to go out and get our
nails done and get our hair done stuff
like that you know the vanity aspects of
things whereas um men primarily wouldn't
be doing that yeah you know going back
to what you said as well a man would be
more like okay I'm going to work my
children need to be taken care of is
there dinner on the table that type of
thing but um with women
it's a bit different and I don't want to
sound like a what do people say pick me
and stuff like that oh you sounded like
a pig you know but you know what
honestly this is no but this is this is
my standpoint you know I come from a
single parent household I grew up with
my dad like for majority of the time but
I got to a point where my dad wasn't
involved and I saw the way my mom has
been throughout all of that because um
one of the ladies was saying it before
um I can't remember who was saying it
but there's a certain type of closure
that comes with when a father passes
away and a woman understands like maybe
what her place was in that Dynamic and
the father passes away but when there's
like infidelity etc etc and the father
is kicked out it's a different type of
dynamic so um for me the way my mom's
always been she's been very selfless
she's always put myself on my brother
first and I feel like that's built
certain levels and certain principles
and values within us that do come from
scripture do come from the most high but
I feel like yeah sorry I lost my train
of thought but I just I feel like
I feel like women have a lot to assess
in this day nature it's not just
entirely because of women society as a
whole has a lot to answer for but we do
need to do a lot of you know reflection
on what our goals are and you know as
you said women aren't really wanting to
have children so that just shows you
right off the bat women aren't trying to
put children for themselves because they
know once they have children I think
it's a I think this the society we live
in is quite
is quite anti-life I agree I think it's
quite anti-life especially when it comes
to
um the importance of children like we've
just had you know in America the road
versus great case and people have gone
crazy about it and it's like people are
now arguing
whether or not life should exist and I
think that is actually I think that's
actually
it speaks the society in which we live
in like with this it's just an anti-life
Society you know what I think about a
lot if there was a dog that they were
pulling off the limbs one by one
crushing the soul yeah and skull and
sucking it out of the womb like people
would have a different opinion it's
crazy but it's weird because when it's
like an actual kid they don't care yeah
yeah I think the type of comments
because I saw a few things online and um
people going up to people asking like
what are your views and a type of
comments that I saw women making I'm
just like wow is this how far gone we've
like how far gone we're in society yeah
I mean I'm not
I mean your your perspective and your
opinions your own but
um
well and they even um
views the other day and someone was like
oh you're brainwashed because you're
American I'm like why is it when a girl
has an opinion that's not the same as
most women and where I'm automatically
brainwashed like can't as a woman I
think for myself or you're supposed to
go down the liberal I guess as a woman
yeah yeah that's what you're supposed to
do and if you're a conservative woman
then yeah you're brainwashed and you're
a pick mean whatever it gets to the
point like you know you're having a
conversation like what is a woman now
like you don't want to have kids but
what is a woman like you see that now is
all you know that that commentary that
comes from that side also how much
degeneracy can you push in society
before people go no I've had enough yeah
I remember I saw a meme the other day
and it has a picture of Wonder Woman and
the debate whether a woman so the first
meme was in 1960 this was Wonder Woman
now what is a woman yeah it's true I
think it's kind of like a good thing
though that we are kind of moving away
from this representation